okay okay hello believe nation welcome
to another one on one google+ hangout I
am Evan Carmichael i'm here with with
enrich tatarskiy who has been one of my
loyal followers on twitter and youtube
and commenting on twitter chats and been
a great supporter um but those you're
watching a video i am bleeding right now
from a shaving cut that happened this
morning so you can excuse me if i use a
Kleenex every now and then um so this is
being broadcast to my audience as well
as in rich's audience and we're going to
talk about Google+ today and so for
those of you who don't know me uh Evan
Carmichael I believe in entrepreneurs my
mission is to help a billion
entrepreneurs and that's happening for
my website and for my youtube channel
I'm very active on social media very
active on youtube I do two new videos
that come out every day and as a result
i'm active on google+ and so when image
roped me to say hey we want to interview
you for a google+ thing we're doing can
you answer these five questions i said
hey why don't we do a video on it and
and you can ask me live and get some
interaction going and he said yes so
that's why we're doing this and that's
my story aah over to you sir
introduction what is all about thank you
so much even I'm so excited to be here
with all of you of course especially
with you I'm sorry to be to be due to
others but but I was focusing mainly on
you because I'm a big fan of you not
only on Twitter battle also as you have
mentioned on the Google+ past I share
then I appreciate ur let's say focus on
the same values as you are doing so I'm
also trying to help as much as I can of
course to the people which are around me
and here is for vecchia I'm trying to
help them like a project manager and
also why mentoring three startups over
here so basically that's it so I don't
know if there is any question we can
talk about it to introduce ourselves
more
if not then I would go for basically the
questions because i'm looking forward to
to see you Lawrence Peralta video
answers so let's do it okey okey so the
first one how would you define it like
why do you think that we should use the
social Google+ as a social network so
this is the first one I don't know
whether it is a one but why should we
use it why should use it and how would
you define it from your perspective um
so when Google+ first came out I didn't
know if we should use it ah the only
reason I started using it was because it
was google it was a Google product and
google dominates search so much that if
you want to you know if you're trying to
build a brand kind of build a company
you need to be you need to be in the
results and Google's putting something
behind it and they were putting a lot of
and they still are a lot of resources
and effort to make this thing go it's
their own social network I mean I'll
still define it as a show social network
at the start there were very few people
on it except for some really tech savvy
people and so if you're looking for
distribution it wasn't the number one
place to go you also get better leverage
out of Twitter and Facebook and and
still now like you'll still get way more
leverage out of Twitter and Facebook
it's grown and especially with the you
eat um where the comments are showing up
on google+ and on youtube that's made a
big difference for me and that made me
pay a lot more attention to it because
of how active I am on youtube so um
because it's google and because they put
a lot of importance on this i would say
it should be a key part of anybody's
social media strategy and just the top
of those questions which i have prepared
before so that means that more users are
coming from the google plus two to a
YouTube channel or not
yeah so the integration so YouTube
comments that the YouTube comments were
changed I love you too comments it's my
favorite part of the day i wake up i
turn on my computer and I start checking
at my youtube comments and responding to
people and youtube comments were totally
changed around to be integrated with
google plus so now all the comments to
leave a comment you have to have a
Google+ account gmail account that's
tied to it and the old comments are
still there but you can't leave it would
format that used to be so you have to
have that google plus account when you
post a comment on youtube it also gives
you the option to add it to your google+
account as well to give that more
exploit i think it may even be default
turned on i'm not sure but the the
integration between Google Plus and
YouTube made it a lot more attractive
for me because of how much I'm doing on
youtube if you're doing YouTube then you
have the young google+ yeah okay so
thank you so that for that so the second
question would be uh what is different
from your perspective of course if you
compared Google+ to Facebook Twitter or
LinkedIn because there are a lot of
differences for my perspective but I
would like to hear also your run sure um
well let's start with linkedin I don't I
don't actually do a lot on linkedin I
don't get a lot of value from LinkedIn
when when it was first starting up um I
was I was one of the top people in
Canada on linkedin and adding everybody
and and you know they used to show you
how connected you were and how many in
your country what your position was and
I was like top hundred in the country on
linkedin but I wasn't getting enough
value from it for the time I was putting
in and so I post some of the usual stuff
social media stuff that I'm hosting but
I'm not very active I'm not in groups
i'm not i'm not part of any of that
stuff so i can't really compare it to
linkedin mostly because i don't
personally get enough value at a
linkedin to the share don't honest i'm
sorry for interrupting you but to be
honest i can imagine that so i can
understand it
because you are so active on the Twitter
and I think that this is the main
channel probably you approve it or not
ah but what you are doing for me it
would be not a waste of time to be on
linkedin and to be active on Linkedin
but it is not that sudden it is not
something which is let's say familiar
for you to be used for the for what you
are doing so for me it's obvious like
like how that you the twitter is the the
top priority and to see how many movies
you are you are sharing youtube is like
wow so so i think that that Lincoln is
like as a set like a waste of time to be
there to do something something really
there yeah linkedin the power is in the
groups and I'm not reactive in the
group's so maybe I should you know maybe
I should have my own believe group and
and create it up I don't know I mean I
haven't been convinced yet so I haven't
done it um but I could be way wrong you
know I'm just not getting the value from
it yet it work is YouTube I love the
videos i love the video format I love
the comments in the community that are
on there and so the Google+ to me is
tied into that if I'm compared with the
twitter twitter is my number two
platform right now after you youtube I
like that everything is open um I like
that you can tag people and they'll see
it writing a tag know the president you
can tag you know celebrities famous
entrepreneurs and and they may not you
know they may not person respond but
some of them do I like that you can call
out brands if I have a bad negative
experience you know with the company
I'll usually tagged them on Twitter and
say what's up you know I was at I was I
was going down town last weekend and
they had these free sample yogurts that
they were giving out and so I mean I got
my yogurt and and it was moldy on the
side like these three things are hanging
out or moldy and so I I went to Twitter
and called the mountain say hey you guys
are giving out moldy samples I usually
result I what's that I'm sorry bidding
in my how many followers do you have
I've on Twitter that could be pretty bad
for the company if you information that
put sudden them yeah yeah I mean smart
smart brains will will reach out
regardless of how big you are but having
the size of followers that i have got
like two hundred thousand something
followers you got um that that helps
that helps get a response faster and so
it's quite like if you if you're trying
to build a business you want to reach
out connect with people you want to
introduce yourself it's so easy to get
direct access now through twitter and
google+ is going there google+ you can
tag people and you can tag pages it's
just them are they on you know are your
clients on google+ so that you can pack
them out so it's it's heading that way
you know it's just everybody's on
twitter and not everybody's on google+
so the power isn't there quite yet uh
and then converted to facebook i don't
use facebook so this to this your brand
pages and then there's your your your
actual page I don't use facebook all
that much on a personal level a little
bit in touch with some friends and
family but I'm not a heavy facebook user
um the brand page we do use a lot and it
used to be my favorite place to be
before YouTube and Twitter as how r
started and social um I don't know I
just find that it's I don't get as much
engagement for activity on facebook I
think mom now you have to pay a lot more
to get your your your post put up and I
never pay for any of mine none of my
stuff has ever boosted or advertised and
so there's a loyal for audience there on
facebook and I check every day still
when I engage with them every day still
um but I think it became an issue of
there's only one news feed on people's
facebook when they login and so they're
they're liking so many pages and have so
many friends how does Facebook decide
what gets shown in that stream and they
they're really monetizing it they're
really focusing on brands pain to get in
there uh and i don't i don't know
I try to create content that speaks to
people and people want to share engage
with and I don't focus so much on the
advertising side so maybe that's what
google plus goes eventually where they
have so much popularity that it's it's
hard to like how do you determine what's
in your stream grace' limit wing
Facebook and Twitter Facebook you're
going to facebook com and you're looking
at what's in the stream nobody is going
to twitter com to see what's in their
stream everybody the tool HootSuite
something right everybody has a tool to
manage it so what's the goal Google+ you
know with with a hoot suite I can then
manage my own stream and put people into
different buckets as I want so we'll
have different filters that pull up who
I actually care about where Facebook i'm
relying on facebook to do that sorting
for me i do have the lists and stuff
that you can use on facebook but it's
not as common so where does google+ go
does it go the facebook strategy where
we will decide what is the most relevant
you know stuff for you to look at or
does it go in a Twitter roof where it
opens up the EPI and say okay use these
tools that the main page is going to be
a flood gates of the most recent stuff
mm-hmm though is still early um you know
I'd like you could tag people out if
they're actually on Google+ but my group
house is going to be to Twitter for that
kind of stuff yeah just the side note
for my side uh I think that Google+ can
have as a really advantage of knowing
comparison to those then a social
network that it is integrated with other
powerful tools like Maps the search
engine and and and the YouTube as you
said already so so this is something
which these platforms but they won't or
not they don't have so so this is a very
powerful tool and very big advantage in
comparison to other social network
question is when and how it will come up
and better users will be will be more
building
to use it or not because of that there's
a question also for me so but this is
just as I said just as a side note okay
so from your side in the recommendation
how we should behave here I mean on the
Google+ for what we should or shouldn't
do on google+ from your experience um so
I treat what I post on Google+ similar
to what I post on facebook I find it
more of a picture economy right Facebook
your posting pictures twitter is more
links right so more of a link economy so
it's more visual so i'm posting the
pictures i'm posting to basically the
same stuff that I post on Facebook I
post on Google+ I don't find a lot of
difference in terms of the content
between the two so I approach from the
same strategy so I don't know how many
times a day maybe five times a day we're
posting something to the google plus
account right again it's just a repeat
of everything is going to the Facebook
page nine what's kind of specific about
it that that maybe people watching and
learn from and I'm still learning I'm
still kind of deeper into it but some
ways that I use it one I love the
hangouts feature that's actually
something different because everything
else you can find another network it's
only because it's google that people pay
a little bit attention to it but the
hangouts thing is unique and it's so
easy to do a video hangout that you can
either record like we're doing now or or
just to be looking municate with your
team and see each other i love that
feature and so now every time somebody
asked me to do an interview like you
said hey I've got these five questions
let's have a can you and your answer
them from your an email my default
answer is hey let's do a Google+ Hangout
the chat about it so that helps build a
little more rapport and also for my
audience watching they can also learn
from the advice and I almost don't do
any interviews anymore that aren't
video-based through hang out um yeah and
like even with bigger brands and clients
they want to get me to do an interview
for
orbs or whatever it is I'll always try
to push your google+ hangout it's easier
for me and more fun and it I you to the
audience who can pay attention and
watching so that's one easy strategy
right if you're trying to launch a
youtube channel and Google+ as part of
that then anytime you're doing an
interview either being the interviewee
or doing the interview itself say hey
let's do it on google plus dou um the
other cool thing if your youtube user is
on the insights it lets you see who your
top fans are your top community are
people who are commenting the most on
your videos and you can create a circle
of them mm-hmm and that's automatic you
just press the button create a circle
and it'll take all the people who are
the most active on your channel and I
think I think you're on there a couple
times is you leavin comments on my
videos so you think you're very mad
circle and what I'll do is every week
I'll do this or every Monday I'll go in
and make that list and then move
everybody into a circle that I have
called YouTube fans and that is almost
5,000 people right now on that YouTube
Franz Liszt and basically what it does
is so these people all of my circles now
every day in the morning I'll go to my
Google+ and and I'll usually comment on
somebody's post I don't know what the
filter is I don't even know if there is
a filter it's just most recent orbit
actually filters out by relevance or or
what's popular I think it's just most
recent like Twitter does it yeah it
might be look at them so I'll usually
find somebody's post that I mean these
people are hardcore fans so the stuff
that that that they like I'm probably
going to like to their posting maybe an
inspirational quote or speech or
something picture and and i'll just
leave a quick comment on it and for some
of them you know they may not have ever
talked to me but then it's kind of cool
to open up your google+ and though i
haven't left a comment on my picture
that nobody has left a comment on and so
it's just another way to kind of touch
your community and touch your fans um
and I just I just picked like one or two
a day and it's totally random is
has been post recently um the other cool
thing about it is there's a birthday
notifications and so usually every day
I'll check what birthday notifications
there are and I'll just wish people a
happy birthday I niching no checking
Facebook for that was exactly i don't
have the facebook I don't have I don't
use facebook i use face it personally
right like uh my my facebook my YouTube
fans are not my personal facebook
friends and you're also limited I don't
know what the limit is that I think it's
a couple thousand I don't because how
many friends you can have your not
limited on the brand your brand page but
as far as I can see there isn't a
birthday doesn't tell you when your fans
birthdays are maybe it's aaron i missed
it if it is it's not obvious that should
be more obvious when i'm in class when
you hit your Google+ home page at the
top right it'll say today's birthdays
and then you can click on it and it
automatically crafts a birthday message
let's say happy birthday whatever and I
just out of hashtag believe on the end
of it and I'm just saying a birthday
message did you know it every day um I
try usually during the week I'll do it
if I'm if I'm in the city I'm not
traveling I'm just another easy way to
you know these are my hardcore fans and
it's an easy way to recognize them and
make them feel a little bit special mmm
what about those dolls that so what do
you don't click Matt do is there
anything which you have faith been in
the impasse that something you it was
not that that that good and you are not
going to repeat it again don't I think
that the don't with Google+ are going to
be the don'ts that are applying to the
other social media strategies right you
know the other network so you know don't
don't just push content in people's
faces don't just promote yourself all
the time don't just chill go because you
wrote it right like everything you post
needs to you have to be used to feel
proud about everything that
putting up there you gotta feel proud of
you like yeah I made that I'm really
happy about that thing I've made or if
you're sharing somebody's content
picture whatever it moves you and makes
you feel something and not one for any
in social certain social networks um the
the works alone that boast yeah what's
that well so some personality some some
something edit it yourself yeah
something that makes you feel something
right look even if it's not even if you
didn't make it like if you watch my
video and you love it then and then
share it like that's great that's
totally cool and I do that if i watch a
video that I really like all share or
two even if I'm not adding anything to
it just because I really liked it but
you don't want to just be promoting
stuff all the time because it if you
look at and this is like most people on
google+ on twitter on facebook they're
just pumping out garbage like they're
pumping out promotional stop check out
my latest article by my lid program with
this coupon it's it's it doesn't work
but if they're using just as a way to
get distribution instead of actually
create a conversation so everything that
you create should be something that
you're proud of either proud of making a
proud of sharing from somebody else's
content specific the Google+ is one
really annoying feature that some people
use where you can add anybody to a
circle yep and they don't have to
approve it right so i could add you to a
circle and and you're in my circle
whether you like it or not you're in
myself lucky and then you can invite
people from your circle to your events
so like this hanger that we did I can
create a circle and invite people to it
and it's just another form of spam and
I'm surprised will hasn't cracked down
on it more they've limited how many
people you can invite to an event so
that cuts down a little bit but I'm
getting Google+ notifications from
people every single day who I've no idea
who they are and they're promoting this
whatever google+ hangout that I've never
heard of before because they in their
circle and
I have no way that I know of at least
right now to get out of it so that's
something specific to Google Plus that
that doesn't make a lot of sense but
hopefully will change but the other
don'ts I think are the same that you
would apply to all the other social
strategy fully agree with it okay thanks
for that and last two questions
basically you already have mentioned
both of them but let's see yeah we are
still so Google good+ as you said you
have said is still moving somehow so
it's still growing in still finding his
own or its own position between our
incorporation to do to other social
networks and it should be learn
continuously the best way how to use it
or or or it's enough if we check that
okay this is how it works and that's it
basically i think it's worth investing
time to learn even you know i wish i
knew some of these things that I'm doing
a google plus i wish i knew that before
you know the ability to create a circle
for your top YouTube fans and then you
know move them into a bigger circle and
then be able to follow them and see what
they're up to and main happy birthday
and doing Google+ Hangouts like all of
this stuff I just kind of learned you
know I'll just kind of fooling around
and I mean you to like oh I can create a
circle okay cool let's put them in right
but there's no education around it and
how people are using it to grow their
businesses and I'm sure there's a lot of
other techniques that may be through
your interview series and programs will
learn how other people are using google
plus and I'll all learn together but I
think it's worth investigating I'm
getting a lot more value from Google+
now than I was before and I'm sure I
could get more value by applying other
strategies that i'm not using yet that i
just don't know you don't know what you
don't know you know i don't know what
what what I what I should be doing that
I'm missing so I'm happy with how I'm
using it i'm using it more than a lot of
people
I'm I don't pretend to know everything
about Google+ so I'm sure there's a lot
more the creepy learn I'm looking
forward to seeing the results of all
your interviews that's for sure look
okay so the last question we had four
minutes last question you have also have
mentioned that from your perspective how
the idea of post looks like like well if
if I will live do if I would like to get
the best engagement and the best impact
like to let's say get a traffic to my or
less a boxer side or the movie were you
are saying there or whatever else so and
this again applies to any social media
network not just Google Plus but it
comes back to posting content that
matters yeah everything that gets posted
on your channel should one make you feel
something and to make you proud of
sharing and it's okay to have some
things that are that are promotional and
that are showcasing what you're up to
but that's like you know ten to twenty
percent of your channel or the other
eighty ninety percent should be on
adding value and sharing most of the
time it's sharing things are easy to
digest asmo and sharing a picture or
full or a video something that people
can consume quickly and what you want to
do is build up brand familiarity and and
goodwill and curiosity so people will
want to check out what you're all about
if they see all these great quotes and
pictures come from your account the one
and check out the link that you have in
your bio and they'll go to your homepage
and then they'll see what's on your
homepage what does this person do you
know for people who who respond to me a
lot right so I like I checked out your
your your Twitter page in your website a
while ago because you were really active
on YouTube sharing my stuff on Twitter
and so for people who are really active
with my content I'll check out the who
they are right drives curiosity and so
then it's not so much you know if you if
you tweet to me and say I've knowing who
you are you tweet you mean say hey Ivan
check out my website it's got great
information I'm not going to go like I
get that all day long I get tons of
people writing to me saying trying to be
on whatever their website is and I never
check it out but if you are responding
to stuff that I'm posting and adding
value and and seeing great job or adding
your own two cents on it then even
though you never even promoted anything
to me it drives curiosity for me to
learn about you I'm going to click on
your profile and I'm going to click
through your website and now you've
accomplished your goal without telling
me go click on my website because you're
adding value and so that's what most
people are missing where they're just
trying to sell stuff and and I get it
like you maybe I'm trying to I need to
get sales you know my business is dying
I'm struggling and so it's a short-term
fix like okay I got i can send it out to
this list of a thousand people and one
person will click on it and that's maybe
a sale there's such a short term gain or
if you build relationships and add value
and get people to know you like you
trust you the more likely to want to
click through on your website even if
you never even promote it because you
can learn about you okay so well thank
you so much for everything you have
shared with me and all with all of us
basically we have one minutes to go and
I just bring it ah basically oh my last
comment would be that I like also your
salsa videos because I've also also been
I also did it in my past with my wife so
so we danced a lot so that's what I'm a
and join also that one and i hope i
believe of course that they'll have a
chance to follow you in that vice too so
let's limit point and this is another
awesome strategy that people should use
on social they share some personal stuff
and when i started i'm like well who
wants to know about me like this is
stick with that you're here you don't
want to know what I'm eating for lunch
and dinner and dancing whatever but um
and you don't want to make it a hundred
percent just all about you but adding a
little personality to it helps people
connect to you better and help people
feel like they they they'll trust you
more and so then when you have an
important message to share they're going
to listen to you and it helps the
all of the hardcore fans so on my
youtube channel usually eighty to ninety
percent of the content is is business
it's asked answering questions it's it's
me ranting about something sharing a
famous entrepreneur story and then the
other ten the twenty percent will be
something personal my trip to Asia meet
salsa dancing my wife cooking dinner
whatever right and there's fun moments
in there and you can find lessons to
teach in there to the people watching
other more the hardcore fans and then
they come and they watch the other
videos more they ever they feel like
they know me and when people feel like
they know you the more likely to take
whatever action that you want them to
take yeah yeah exactly exactly fully
agree with that so I really enjoy I
don't know what what about others but I
really enjoy it so we will see the
interactions over there ah I didn't
didn't read anything so probably will
see later on ah and let's see let's see
cool well thanks for the time and where
can people learn more about you and this
one even are you releasing this easy
interviews and a anyone I think that we
didn't build in a week because we need
to we need to add those subtitles as I
said yeah so and as soon as they finish
that definitely within the vegan we will
share it so definitely I will share its
Peter booster and a few friends which
which will share it too so so basically
we will create a great bus to get around
so definitely but you're interviewing
other people too right yeah yeah yeah
sure when is that cats what I want to
read when is that stuff coming in so
basically something is already there but
only sort language so i will provide can
I can I can do translation for you so if
if you are interested in basically there
is a linkedin interview I I was
interviewed also regarding the sweeter
okay ah so no problem so we can we can
do it and we can share did you also okay
so you know
come out maybe we'll add it to the
description of this video so people
watching can I'm gonna check it out but
they can they can check it out too elke
agree agree thank you for the
opportunity so great thanks to the time
it's been fun for me of course too so
all right good day and I hope that we
will see each other soon absolutely
Cheers a big cow